madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre chers
collègues vous entrez dans le livre des
record non pas parce que vous êtes le
plus jeune premier ministre mais parce
que vous êtes le nouveau Premier
ministre du président de tous les
tristes record record d'endettement avec
788 milliards supplémentaires depuis
2017 record de déficit commercial record
de déficit budgétaire avec en 2023
presque le montant de 2020 record
d'immigration avec deux fois plus de
séjours de premier titre de séjour
record d'insécurité avec plus 63 % de
coût et blessures depuis 2017 et bien
sûr record d'impopularité car on ne peut
pas éternellement confondre présidence
d'impopularité car on ne peut pas
également confondre présidence de la
République et agence de
communication vous devez vivre monsieur
le Premier ministre dans le même monde
parall
qu'Emmanuel Macron pour avoir osé cet
après-midi qualifier son bilan de
concret tangible et solide je comprends
mieux pourquoi Emmanuel Macron vous a
choisi j'attendais un premier ministre
j'ai découvert un porte-parole un seul
discours aura donc suffi pour comprendre
que votre nomination ne changera rien et
cela pour deux raisons
principales la première
c'est que le président Emmanuel Macron
est le vrai Premier ministre comme sa
conférence de presse l'a démontré
comment allez-vous conforter les classes
moyennes alors qu'avant même ce discours
de politique générale Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé lui-même l'augmentation des
franchise sur les médicaments et Bruno
lomer l'augmentation du tarif de
l'électricité dans un autre domaine
celui de l'éducation nationale comment
allez-vous pouvoir répondre à toutes les
demandes de l'Élysée cours de théâtre
cours de sport instruction CIVI à des
élèves qui ont besoin avant tout
d'apprendre à lire en matière de
sécurité comment allez-vous faire
baisser la délinquence en conservant un
garde des saau et une politique
judiciaire profondément laxiste et en
étant fier de laisser détricoter une loi
sur l'immigration qui était déjà bien
insuffisante enfin dans le domaine du
logement vous ne manquez pas de culot
pour annoncer un choc de l'offre alors
que depuis 2017 vous avez
systématiquement saboté tous les
mécanismes d'aide au logement la seconde
raison pour laquelle vous êtes condamné
à parler dans le vide à agiter des
éléments de langage éternellement
ressassé depuis 2017 et que si le
premier ministre est à l'Élysée le vrai
président est malheureusement à Bruxell
c'est Madame Van derleen qui vous donne
des ordres matin midi et soir en est mes
chers collègues la Commission européenne
vient d'annoncer à l'instant des
pêchesretaire que vous pouvez vous
procurer que les négociation avec le
mercosour continuaiit bien infligeant un
nouveau camouflé à l'Élysée qui
prétendait hier qu'elles étaient stoppé
de même au moment où vous tentiez
d'éteindre l'incendie agricole en tenant
un discours assis sur une botte de foin
un consultant en communication avait
vous dû vous suggérer que cela ferait
bien et les députés européens
renaissance après avoir déjà approuvé la
nouvelle Pâque et ses achèes votaient en
faveur de l'accord de libre échange avec
le Chili après ceux avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande avec le Kenya avec le
Vietnam enfin enfin vous avez préféré ça
vous fait rire donner des gages au
gouvernement allemand plutôt que de
baisser le tarif de l'électricité en
sortant du marché européen comme on su
le faire l'Espagne et le Portugal
alors pour faire oublier vos doubles
discours successifs vous êtes condamné à
multiplier les effet d'annonce vous nous
avez livré cet après-midi un concours un
catalogue de mesurettes avant-hier
l'éducation était au-dessus de tout hier
c'était l'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est
le travail en définitive vous me faites
penser à ces jongleurs d'assiette qui
dans les cirques sont obligés d'en
ajouter toujours plus pour tenir en
haleine le spectateur jusqu'au jour où
patatra ell se brisent toutes ce moment
est proche car les Français ne se
portent plus les fausses promesses les
injonctions contradictoires le manque de
sérieux et de maturité dans la conduite
de l'État la disparition de la
souveraineté populaire sans majorité
dans cet hémicycle vous serez obligé
comme votre prédécesseur de multiplier
jusqu'à plus soif les 493 et plutôt une
motion de censure nous libérera de cette
mauvaise pièce de théâtre pour avec de
nouvelles élections législatives
permettre au peuple d'arbitrer et plus
vite la souffrance des Français la nôtre
et la vôtre Monsieur le Premier Ministre
seront abrégé je vous REM
merci